[Applause]
that's why podcast phantom is so
different like you just
i think i was quoted to see you guys but
somebody said it to me that's the
closest you can get to being
inside someone's brain yeah is they have
you in earbuds listening to you for
hours a week
just you talking and talking about
yourself and whatever and even if they
don't get to talk back
they're they feel like they're have
they're a part of the conversation and i
think that's why when they see you
they're so [ __ ] hyped because it's
like yo
we're friends you just don't know it yet
i've been waiting to talk to you because
i hear you talk all the time
and here we finally get to go and that's
why the podcast fandom is like a
different thing
it's a different beast yeah yeah we
definitely don't know the kardashians
because
the fact that kim wasn't upset
over kanye's gift that he gave her of
the dad's hologram
like the fact that she like liked that
and was like i think she cried she was
so happy about it like
i saw that [ __ ] i was like yo that's
some weird [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's some weird [ __ ] [ __ ] and he
had the [ __ ] dad
saying like yo your husband's the best
he's the he's a genius like
that's brilliant that's right that's
game bro
i love that that [ __ ] was fired up
that's just super fire bro i like that
right
you would like your girl to do that say
what you would like your girl to do that
first waste of a gift but girls like
those kind of thoughts
you would do that [ __ ] i would do that
i'd be like yo
this [ __ ] is lit yeah schultzy
i thought that was the weirdest thing no
no i understand but it is like
as corny as as kanye is like
i think that was a really kind of
thoughtful gift oh i don't think unique
i do think he had like intentions of
being like this was going to be the best
thoughtful gif yeah i just don't
understand her that she
enjoys it apparently they asked for a
moment alone with the hologram the
family was like so moved they were like
yo can we just be alone with
dad for a bit which is why sam khan is
the best of all time
some pre-programmed skills what's he
even going to say after this this script
is done
yeah what does that would be don't you
start singing jesus
i tried to be objective and be like if i
liked this celebrity
how would i feel about them doing this
and i was like yo every celebrity i like
like bill burr whoever would never do
some [ __ ] like this but would you want
to see someone who had passed
no from your family no no no if it's a
if it's
a hologram of them and then you gave
them a script it's like what am i
looking at
i can look at pictures and have actual
memories but this is just weird
would you talk to a medium actually
scares me
no oh you really wouldn't do it i'm not
completely closed off to it but it
scares me
that's like why aren't you scared about
it you can't open that door bro what do
you mean what door
what if my grandparents think i'm dumb
or something i'm saying
you won one or no no i wouldn't do that
i don't need to know about it actually
it's so funny when i ask people it's
like they're like oh now i'm afraid of
that [ __ ] i don't like you think if you
go into that world all of a sudden it
opens up and now like
spirits are gonna come see you i don't
think about it i just think it's
[ __ ] so i'm like i'm not about to
get gamed up and then you tell me what i
want to hear that's the other thing
you're manipulating me
on the highest level logically yeah it's
kind of emotionally it's like
you think it's complete [ __ ] i think
it's kind of evil low-key
because it's like you're taking
advantage of people who really
miss their loved ones and you're telling
them everything they want to hear
so maybe there's something like good
with that but the reality is
you're not letting them kind of separate
and like build a life without
them now you're enabling this you're
enabling the sickness right
somehow the hologram is okay that's what
i'm saying in the hologram the exact
same thing
why you are manipulating these people
into thinking this person is still here
and you're just feeding them what they
say because if
you think that they saw the hologram
they're like oh he's real
that might have been the single dumbest
thing you've ever said on these people
that's not true no you said no that's
way
no my point is they all knew it was fake
and this is
an homage to the father that's all it
was but
the the medium is going i am connecting
with your
dead relative that you are not over yet
to the point where you're willing to
talk to some gypsy
in a [ __ ] store window yeah that's
how vulnerable you are and like
making people pay you to talk to their
dead ones
that [ __ ] just makes me feel
uncomfortable well i caution might not
be wrong because they asked for a moment
alone so they could speak to him
just to like be with that person to me
it's no to me i'd liken this to
like um you want to see a grave maybe or
something oh it's like a grave but also
like
have you ever seen that video it's a
really sweet video this girl got her
boyfriend a teddy bear for
uh his birthday or something like that
he had the voice and it had a voicemail
from his father who had passed and it
was like the last voicemail the father
left on the kids right
and he just like hugged it and he like
relived this real moment that he had
whatever and
what i saw from the kim's hologram video
was
um he was like saying certain things
that they used to do remember we used to
sing this song on the way to school and
so this wasn't like actual conversation
it was just like hear
these memories like a picture hear these
memories i'd like you to have
right that's what i and listen i'm the
most critical of kanye i think he's a
connor 100
all i'm saying is this was thoughtful
and it's like a cool way of instead of
going here's pictures collage with your
dad it's like hey remember we used to do
that
yeah i thought his voice yeah let me
give you a different scenario what if it
was a hologram
deep fake and there's somebody listening
and interacting with back
that's the next level do you have a
problem with it no i wouldn't have a
problem with it
that's a medium no because you're not
grifting like you're not pretending like
this is like yo this is fake and i have
somebody no i'm saying
the person speaking to the hologram
doesn't know that there's another person
who's
responding then that's wrong yeah that
and then that's wrong because then
they're gonna start thinking how the
[ __ ] does this person know that
like what's going on they have to know
okay that you're not feeding and like
profiting off of their
deepest pain yeah it's almost like a
play like someone made a musical about
your parents life or some [ __ ] yeah it's
great
it's a cool homage and the fact that
it's interactive would be cool too like
they have those interactive plays where
like you can kind of talk to the
characters and they speak to you like in
character and it's like okay that's fine
i don't know just that that medium [ __ ]
[ __ ] with me a little bit i wonder if
oj feels some type of way looking at
that [ __ ]
definitely dude like a little bit
grateful or something yeah it's like
batman
they should have invited him right like
it's kind of [ __ ] really difficult do
you think oj gets a johnny cochran
hologram yeah
did you watch that well rob kardashian
defended him too yeah yeah but
apparently
rob kardashian like was his good friend
and then as the trial was going on he
was like
oh this [ __ ] did that is that
right
that's what i've heard yeah do you think
that might be what the kardashians say
to protect the fact that
their dad defended defended a [ __ ]
murderer
it's possible they put that narrative
out there yeah i would but i know i
he also was like more and more isolated
as johnny cochran took more and more of
a prominent role
he got more and more push of the
background but early on i remember only
hearing about robert kardashian
yeah and then it all became johnny
cochran oj probably wish he had that
hologram when he stole all those jerseys
and went back to jail and [ __ ]
yeah he's like where's his hologram when
my [ __ ] attorney was getting me
locked up yeah
sure they had to go with cochran because
they made it the race trial yeah cochran
was smart
you had to do with cocker you can't have
rob kardashian come in look at the
racism it has to be
johnny up there with an african tie
remember he put on the kinte cloth yeah
he's pulled in any pull up
that [ __ ] was brilliant i didn't even
know that yeah apparently the fx series
i remember i watched the first episode
and they paint robert kardashian as kind
of like a star [ __ ] more than a great
lawyer
he's talking about somebody who reps wme
at dinner or something like that and
he's like
they kind of paint him as one of those
[Applause]
kardashians
you